pasan los días poco a poco va imponiendo
su mensaje de normalidad pero también
vamos conociendo más detalles sobre cómo
se resolvió la intentona armada más
grave que ha sufrido Vladimir Putin en
estos más de 20 años que lleva en el
poder hoy el crimen ha revelado que
Vladimir Putin se reunió con el jefe de
los amotinados con el líder de Wagner
apenas cuatro días después de que se
resolviese la intentona no vino solo y
pregosin le acompañaban varios
comandantes un nutrido grupo de
comandantes de Wagner hasta 35 personas
según ha informado el crème que ha dicho
que la cita duró por lo menos tres horas
en esa reunión los jefes de Wagner le
aseguraron a Vladimir Putin que seguían
siendo sus soldados y que seguirían
luchando para él si él así lo deseaba
conocíamos que Vladimir Putin cuando
empezó el motín dijo que se trataba de
una traición pero lo que ha sucedido
después en Rusia es que ninguna de las
personas que ha tomado parte han sido
castigados hasta la fecha en el acuerdo
de resolución del motín pregosin el jefe
de los Wagner tenía que exiliarse en
Bielorrusia pero lo último que ha dicho
el presidente bielorruso es que prigosin
ha regresado a su país a Rusia